police departments across Nevada face
major shortages of officers and
employees it was a topic of conversation
in Henderson where the police chief and
mayor spoke to Citizens but it just so
happens also in Henderson they're
building a new police substation 8 news
now investigator Kyle Payne was there
and Kyle you don't think these two
headlines match up do you well Kirsten a
fully functioning police substation
would ideally be staffed 24 7. just like
the Henderson Police Station but the
chief and the mayor said they don't have
enough cops so the eight news now
investigators have to asked if they had
enough people to run that new 22 million
dollar substation
so we're excited to have
meet the mayor Diane Henderson featured
a special guest our brand new
police chief Holly Chadwick who took
over in April told a room full of
Henderson residents some of her main
focus includes road rage incidents
carjackings and pedestrians being killed
between our bodies and a vehicle and I
just don't want to see it anymore we're
emergency too many people but both were
bullish on the new police substation
near the Las Vegas Raiders practice
facility which broke ground in December
2021. it's a beautiful area a beautiful
area command the chief says will only be
partially staffed at least at first
we'll have Control operating
um out of that area command at certain
times of the day certain times of the
day does not mean all day and all night
but the mayor wouldn't concede the point
does that mean that the new substation
will include a three shift rotation I
don't know yet the mayor doesn't know
until the 8 news now investigators they
built it over capacity and would add
more officers as the city grew but they
openly acknowledge that they need more
cops it's important that we continue to
backfill some of the vacancies that have
resulted just due to retirements and um
you know this is a very harsh profession
it's really important that we focus on
Recruitment and that is a goal of the
chief and we're working closely together
to make that happen Carrie Cox is a
Henderson city councilwoman you see any
wisdom in building a new expensive
substation when you don't have enough
people
well I believe the idea is build it and
they will come
councilwoman Cox pointed out that
Henderson's new substation will hold its
new police academy and a
state-of-the-art dispatch area it will
open in the fall and add staff to the
substation in phases over the next few
years and Henderson spokesman says the
city is short 46 employees there the
police chief was sworn in two months ago
after her two predecessors left in less
than ideal circumstances one of them is
suing guys
Henderson police officers start making
about 57 Grand a year at Metro starting
officers make over a dollar more an hour
but most Apartments have a recruitment
problem North Las Vegas is offering a
forty thousand dollar bonus for lateral
transfers